how it started and how it's going deep
fakes the first deep fakes were created
in 1997 using the program video rewrites
this program was able to make a person
say anything the program modeled the
movements of the lips to the appropriate
words and changed the lower part of the
original face to an artificial one my
face is Ellen Ellen did not say these
words these Technologies continued
developing quietly for 10 years until
2017 when Reddit uses deep fakes and
deep fakes Club began to post the first
deep fakes for example deep fakes Club
ridiculed Warner Bros who using Graphics
removed Superman's mustache Henry Cavill
couldn't shave off his mustache as he
was simultaneously starring in Mission
Impossible 6. Warner Bros spent Millions
on the removal of his mustache whilst
our Reddit user deep fakes Club did it
for free now we see how the combination
of AI with CGI Technologies can be used
to create truly amazing results
technology has evolved from replacing
just parts of the face to creating
characters that are already difficult to
tell apart from real people I
I met a human subscribe to some sub